it is rebuttal time the young turks
released this video recently but they
relate the video based on this study
from the Journal of Personality and
Social Psychology to pivot to guess
guess guess right to the MA so they use
this set it up and pivot to white people
are horrible racists who should feel
incredibly guilty sometimes that's true
if we are like for Jared let's let's go
to the clip one to see how they set it
up the researchers asked nearly 1000
online participants to judge the height
weight muscularity and strength of both
black and white men based only on photos
of their faces all participants in the
survey both white and black consistently
overestimated the measurements for black
faces relative to white faces even
though the men picture were all of
similar size okay so that I know
Gerald's are confused it's important to
remember this because this is this is a
factual this is the factual base that's
right this is where it starts okay study
everyone thought that the black people
were larger including black people
themselves ah okay let's start with that
let's go clip two in another experiment
participants were shown the exact same
racially ambiguous body when a person
was labeled as black participants
thought he was taller and heavier than
those who were told he was white okay
now here's where to go after me I'm not
entirely sure the purpose of this study
will have the link in the description uh
it seems a little bit loaded but let's
go with this for a second the reason
that everyone including black
participants saw black people as larger
weather was because they were labeled
black or because they saw people who
were black is probably the same reason
that people who make their livings by
looking big all paint themselves to look
black about the white guy hint it's half
this is well in the fitness industry
that's it that's why they slap on the
tent it is well known that the darker
you are the more tan you are some would
say the closer you can get to black the
larger or more defined you will look
that's an optical illusion kind of like
black clothes are slimming door
your skin tones tend to make you look
more angular more defined and that
creates an optical illusion that you're
larger now is that racist I guess by
definition whenever you separate things
by race and say black people look bigger
than white people that's the perception
by definition it's racist but the mean
that is hateful or making it in a
negative way now but not to be stopped
there they go on to imply that you are
but a difference emerge when the
researchers asked participants whether
the person appeared threatening and if
police force would hypothetically be
justified if that person were a suspect
only the white participants felt the
perceived greater size of the black
faces made them greater threats and more
potentially deserving for so while uh
black individuals in the survey also
overestimated the size they did not then
think as a result of that police are
justified in using force eventually even
lethal force okay so do we right here
yeah so that last little bit ugly purple
yellow Alito Marsha start back it off
with they perceived black people to be
bigger okay including black participants
okay then it goes to so that's a fact
that's a physiological issue then it
goes to with that perception white
people tend to maybe have the opinion
that said black person might be more
likely to commit crime so we say one
thing that's true everyone saw the black
person is bigger black people are
perceived to be larger and then say
therefore racism when white people
perceive there to be a greater set of
crime okay
I know people aren't going to like this
but why would it be that maybe the white
people could perceive it as a greater
threat of crime could it be because
black people who make up only about
thirteen fourteen percent of the
population commit thirty to fifty
percent of the crime oh now does it mean
that although I do little criminals no
doesn't mean that it's okay to
stereotype black people as criminals no
but like Jared said that you talk about
this all the time you can't throw out
the statistic the first in Sarah gsella
one in four black men are you know go to
prison twenty five blah blah blah it's
like you should told me all these stats
about black people good of course I'm
scared
give me white dude what am I going to do
farewell in Harlem so okay okay okay
okay black folks think bigger but they
don't think danger because why among the
reasons why it's because they live with
other black people and they know
day-to-day there isn't like oh my god
we're in constant danger what am ia to
tax me if repaid their interaction is
smaller they have a black friend at work
but they don't live in it it may be in a
city or portion of the city a lot of
african-americans so to them it seems
foreign and an outsider an outsider or
another is always perceived danger yeah
first aspiration that was actually chanc
it was not intended okay right right
Oh at the panel with no black people
what they say is you know what will
presume to be greater threat and they
move to a conclusion based on what
attributing some kind of a motive or a
reason that they couldn't possibly know
it's because of for because things are
just anything that's different to you is
something we're going to be scared of
well actually the Bureau of Justice puts
the crime even higher with 34 to 52
percent of crimes in the United States
being committed by black Americans not
too much when you get into the idea of
altercations with police officers
because we're talking about police
officers using lethal force where
they're more likely to reach for a cop's
gun or they're more likely to assault a
police officer so these are statistical
facts that may come into play when these
people are asked their opinion or
perceptions and then the Young Turks
berate them for simply being racist or
being something that they are that
foreign to them no that's not
necessarily the case and there can be
discussion to be had as far as why is
the crime statistic higher in black B's
what why are black people far more
likely to have a crime committed against
them by black people than by white
people
is it sociological is it economic what's
the reason for is the history in the
United States of America there are a lot
of arguments to be made under
discussions one that people can have I
think some of the arguments are silly
as presented by the Young Turks but
that's not what they're doing here they
just say they're for white people are
racist because they're not familiar
enough with black people and a tribute
an end game and by the way another study
shows that young black kids are
considered by people who are seeing them
as about three to four years older than
the same age white kids because they
were less than 10 years old in all cases
that's right shift so blacks are
perceived as bigger stronger or older
and by white people as more dangerous
maybe they're perceived as older because
there is a scientific study that was
conducted that shows that black males
literally enter puberty a year younger
than white male now I get that sadistic
means that people are different it this
is nothing that we don't know black
people and white people are different
it doesn't inherently mean that one is
better or one is racist for recognizing
the difference then it might not seem a
lot that they enter puberty one year
younger but think about when you were 10
or 11 or 11 or 12 or 15 to 16 right
those kids were great older than you
they were terrifying one makes such a
huge difference at that point absolutely
whether you're an adult even looking
down at those kids they grow up so fast
don't they or a kid it is the magnitude
of that difference of one year that
phase in your life is statistically
significant now I'm not even going as
far as saying that's why young black
males are perceived to be older I think
this could be one of it doesn't
necessarily mean that you asked a whole
bunch of white people who because they
hate black people perceive them to be
older than they are and there could be
one of several reasons um this is one
thing that they take something that's a
statistical fact that is that delineates
people of different races I don't think
we need to be colorblind and eiling's
anything wrong with that therefore and
then make a false equivalency it's like
okay listen nobody would really argue if
you were to say eight for some reason it
seems like black people historically
have been able to achieve greater
highest velocities and white people the
fastest people in history tend to be
black people you look at the records you
go one through fifty and say marry a
white person in sight this ain't about
right so okay we're going to writ seams
for whatever reason that black people
can do historically have been faster
than white people right therefore you're
a white supremists no no that's not true
for example Noah would probably contend
if you say on average black people tend
to be taller than their Asian
counterparts
I think we could probably all agree
there's a physiological difference there
okay
therefore you're not see this is a hoof
weight and it's important the reason I
wanted to well it's important to see the
bait-and-switch
because you can start something off with
with a published study or a published
trial and you can make it sound
scientific enough or you can make it
sound logical enough but you really does
use a lot of time you'll see this and
use not only obviously Young Turks but
at CNN at a lot of any main news outlets
they'll use something entirely
legitimate as a springboard into opinion
and they don't delineator and that's the
danger hey if you like this video you're
probably thinking of subscribing of
course you're thinking of subscribing
right okay this is subscribe button okay
okay